die fußball-wm meine damen und herren
rückt näher und wir alle deutschen sind
wahrscheinlich ja gespannt darauf unsere
deutschen fußball nationalmannschaft dem
titel dieses jahr mal wiederholen kann
und deswegen schaue ich auf meinen tisch
wir spielen heute das spiel namens
soccer weil soccer als amerikaner schon
als fußball
um euch mal kurz zu erklären wie das
ganze spiel funktioniert wir sind diese
beiden personen direkt zum wir haben
noch einen knopf und wenn wir den rücken
passiert dass hier die springen und
schießen gleichzeitig bevor wir uns
allerdings in dieser total bescheuerte
fußballspiel rhein stürzen eine ganz
kurze keine sache und 20 die hier oben
schon serbe video eingeblendet das ganze
hier ist nämlich gerade ein teil
werbevideo und zwar jeder von euch der
mich schon ein bisschen länger kennt
weiß dass sich riesiger fußball fan bin
und da hat mich gefragt ob ich bock
hätte mit ihnen zusammenzuarbeiten und
das passt natürlich super weil ich
selber auf sky kunde bin total ja und
zwar wenn ihr dieses video gerade
sehtest freitag das heißt morgen ist der
letzte spieltag der bundesliga und was
zunächst als hat auch noch kommen dass
der letzte spieltag der zweiten
bundesliga ist kommt das
champions-league-finale es kommt noch
das euro league finales kommen hat das
dfb pokalfinale
und für diese letzten wochen der fußball
saison hat sky jetzt ein super krasses
ultimatives angebot zur verfügung
gestellt und zwar dass crytek wird super
sport das hört sich jetzt so an als wäre
das ultra teuer aber das kostet neun
euro 99 und ihr könnt quasi bis ende
juni alles an sport streamen was
irgendwie geht so sieht die website
übrigens aus als ihr findet ein link in
der beschreibung eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf klickt seht ihr noch mal hier auf
der website die ganzen informationen et
cetera pp also freunde check die info
box ab klickt man auf den link
da kommt ihr nämlich auf die website das
könnt ihr ganz einfach testen für neun
euro 99 m s ist monatlich kündbar und es
geht auf allen gängigen geräten also
iphone android web ipad sogar
playstation und xbox ist auf jeden fall
0 cooles angebot könnt ihr euch einfach
mal anschauen und jetzt spielen wir das
spiel weiter also wir haben wirklich
noch einen knopf und mit diesen knopf
springen die leute und machen einen
kopfball das heißt bam
man geht doch rein ich weiß nicht
welcher verein wir sind so wie es auch
nein das ist jetzt gerade spielen wir
irgendwie gegen unsere eigenen
teamkollegen also vielleicht ist es
einfach ein trainingsmatch gespielt vor
allem auch mit dem basketball was macht
mein torwart da eigentlich hätte was
macht ihr beide darin paar sekunden
später der ball zwischen uns
ich bin kann ich dem
0 zu
jetzt spielen wir gegen solche leute die
irgendwie dinosaurier willst du da
irgend so ein frosch dingen auf haben
oder ins und scheiß werden kommen
das ist kaum junge komm wir kriechen
doch jetzt weg da kommen ja kommt apple
store app store kommen junge das ist
doch nicht so schwer
s
22 ich weiß nicht was man gewonnen hat
der ball geht jetzt auf jeden fall auch
wieder rein also steht jetzt
mittlerweile sogar weit zu zweit denkt
man das ist einfach so bis 5 geht oder
so aber freunde dieses spiel ist ja mal
sowas von bescheuert das ist einfach
unberechenbar wie das ganze funktioniert
also ich weiß nicht wann ich springen
soll wann ich jedes mal wenn ich drücke
denke ich mir okay war das jetzt gut für
mich oder gut für den gegner angriff
kommen und zack
cool
als du zwei kopfball und liedern
kopfball und wieder ein kopfball und der
ist drin freunde das ist es steht 3 3
es ist ein krasses kopf an kopf rennen
wo ist mein torwart
hey
kann ich einmal in slow motion wieder
[Musik]
also ja genauso lieb dann damals auch
mal ab als ich fußball gespielt haben
unser torwart ist einfach immer hätte
das tor gegangen und hatte mein gott
macht ihn rein
kommt jetzt ich brauche torwart jetzt
spielen wir wieder gegen unsere eigenen
leute einmal steht hier zu viel ich weiß
es wirklich bis 50 v
das hat nur noch eine frage der zeit bis
der ball reingeht
ich habe jetzt 6 4 gewonnen meine damen
und herren ich kriege noch 200 gold mehr
wenn ich meine werbung anschauen
ich habe es euch ja bereits schon mal
gesagt freunde ich mag es überhaupt
nicht wenn werbung in apps ist aber
natürlich irgendwie macht es auch sinn
also ich bin ja selber gerade mit einem
kollegen in hamburg und berlin gewesen
weil wir uns mit app entwicklern
getroffen haben weil ich auch eine app
machen möchte endspiel umsatz zu sagen
gar nicht so groß angekündigt aber
einfach mal raus gehauen wir sind ja
gerade halt dabei und haben uns mit
verschiedenen app entwicklern getroffen
soll halt nicht so das upgrade spielwert
oder dass leon machine spiel oder sowas
sollte echt was geiles sein wo wir auch
wirklich hinter stehen wo wir auch eine
menge geld in die hand nehmen also was
nicht irgendwie placement ist für meinen
kanal sondern wir auch eine menge geld
investieren das ist hart teuer so was zu
machen glaubt mir das mal wir überlegen
hat gerade was geiler ist also entweder
man bezahlt für die app und dann hat sie
komplett keine werbung oder man lässt
sich eine app kostenlos herunter und sie
hat werbung und man kann sich immer dann
wenn man dann zwei euro bezahlt ist die
werbung dann weg oder so also was wie
steht ihr dazu schreibt zwar gerne in
die kommentare
sonst würde ich sagen freue ich mich
natürlich über den sieg habe ich
natürlich wieder super gemeistert ich
riesiger fußballprofi aber wie bereits
zu beginn gesagt freundin schenkte
einmal die beschreibung ab klickt auf
den link könnt ja einfach mal testen ist
kostet gesagt 9 eur 99 ihr könnt zwei
monate lang alles an sport trieben was
irgendwie geht es einfach krass und
jetzt würde ich sonst auch einfach das
video an der stelle beenden das wasser
das war's jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder
meinen schenken ihr findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]